to build a neuro style transfer system
let's define a cost function for the
generated image what you see later is
that LP by minimizing this cost function
that you can generate the image that you
want so remember what the problem
formulation is you're given a content
image C given the style image s and you
go is to generate a new image G so in
order to implement neural style transfer
what you're going to do is what you're
going to do is define a cost function J
of G that measures how good is a
particular generator image and we'll use
gradient descent to minimize J of G in
order to generate this image so how good
is a particular image well we're going
to define two parts to this cost
function the first part is called the
content cost this is a function of the
content image and of the generated image
and what it does is it measures how
similar is the contents of the generated
image to the content of the content
image C and then going to add that to a
style cost function which is now a
function of s comma G and what this does
is it measures how similar is the style
of the mhg to the style of the image s
finally we wait these with two hyper
parameters alpha and beta to specify the
relative weighting between the content
cost and the style cost it seems
redundant to use two different hyper
parameters to specify their relative
weighting seems that you know you need
one hybrid it seems redundant to use two
hyper parameters to specify the relative
cost of the weighting one hyper
parameter seems I could be enough but
the original authors of the neural style
transfer algorithm used two different
hyper parameters and so I'm just going
to follow their convention here and the
nearest our transfer algorithm I'm going
to present in the next few videos is due
to Leon Gatti's Alexander occur and
methods and their paper is not too hard
to read so after washing these V videos
if you wish
I certainly encourage you to take a look
at their paper as well if you want
so the way the algorithm will run is as
follows having to find the cost function
J of G in order to actually generate a
new image what you do is the following
you would initialize the generated image
G randomly so it might be 100 by 100 by
3 or 500 by 500 by 3 or whatever
dimensions you want it to be then we'll
define the cost function J of G on their
previous slide so what you can now do is
use gradient descent to minimize this so
you can update G as G minus the
derivative respect to the cost function
of J of G so in this process you're
actually updating the pixel values of
this image G which is a 100 100 by 3 may
be RGB channel image so here's an
example let's say you starts with this
content image and this style image this
is another public picasso image then
when you initialize G randomly your
initial randomly generated image is just
this white noise image with each pixel
value chosen at random and then as you
run gradient descent you minimize the
cost function J of G you slowly treat
the pixel values so then you get slowly
an image that looks more and more like
your content image rendered in the style
of your style image so in this video you
saw the overall outline of the neuro
style transfer algorithm where you
define a cost function for the generated
image G and minimize it next we need to
see how to define the content cost
function as well as the style cost
function let's take a look at that
starting at the next video